هلا وزير الدفاع التركيه خلاص يا كارينا
عمليه المخلب السيف العسكريه مستمره
بالغرب الجويه وبالقصف المدفعي وانه تم
تحديد
326 ارهابيا حتى الان وفق تعبيره
للقضاء على الارهابي وضمان امني تركيا
ومواطنيها وحدودها ونفى ان تكون القوات
التركيه قد استهدفت المدنيين واستهدفت
نقاطا تابعه لقوات التحالف خلال تنفيذ
العمليات العسكريه شمالي سوريا
عدم الاضرار بالمدنيين وبالبيئه خلال ضرب
الارهابي
من جهه قالت ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في بيان لها ان اربعه من
مقاتليها قتلوا خلال القصف التركيه على
بلده تمر بريف الحسكه
خلال الاربعه والعشرين ساعه الماضيه اكثر
من 100 موقع في شمالي وشرق سوريا اتبع
البيان ان الطائرات التركيه ضربت قوات
حمايه مخيم الهول وسجن في القامشلي لديني
يحتجز فيهما عناصر تابعه لتنظيم الدوله او
يحتجزهم فيها
وعوائلهم معهم وان المجتمع الدولي يتحملوا
المسؤوليه الكامله عن ذلك اذا وصل صمته
طالب مدير المكتب الاعلامي لوحدات حمايه
الشعب الكرديه التي تقود ما يعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه ما وصفها بالدول
الصديقه بالوقوف الى جانبته